So we now have a situation and we're going
to have time to have a sort of bigger conversation
about this as we get closer and closer to
Joe Biden's inauguration.
But we have a situation here where Donald
Trump now has cost the Republican Party everything
Trump has cost the Republican Party everything
he could have cost them.
Donald Trump cost the Republican Party, the
House in the twenty eighteen midterms.
Senate.
In the 2012 election, Donald Trump caused
himself to be a one term president, now putting
the Republican Party out of the Oval Office
just 13 days from now.
Donald Trump has cost the Republican Party
global shame and embarrassment and has ruined
the careers of many, many people.
And so we're seeing Republicans start to turn
on Donald Trump.
Donald Trump denounced his own vice president,
Mike Pence, yesterday in the middle of the
Capitol Hill.
Riots that he incited himself.
We saw Mick Mulvaney, who I learned during
the break, went from being Trump's chief of
staff to like an envoy to, I think, Ireland.
And he resigned.
And there are thoughts that there may be more
resignations.
There are thoughts that there are reports
that some cabinet members are thinking about
invoking the 25th Amendment to try to remove
Donald Trump.
So from the point of view of blame and from
the point of view of holding people accountable,
none of these Repub oh, sorry, I hit my mic.
I'm so excited.
None of these Republicans deserve to now be
praised and to be given a blank slate because
with 13 days to go, they said this is too
much for me.
This segment is not about praising the moral
Republicans who after three years and 11 and
a half months, are now saying this is too
much for me.
This is not about that, but this is about
what does the future of the Republican Party
look like.
And in particular, after this week, not only
did Donald Trump incite a seditious riot in
the capital, but he also oversaw the two people
he endorsed.
Carly Lefler and David Perdue lose their Senate
seats as incumbent Republicans.
To Democratic challengers Raphael Warnock
and John Asaph.
You are starting to see Republicans bail and
you start to see these reports like we saw
in the week about Republicans privately furious
at Trump over what happened in Georgia and
Republicans privately furious that Trump put
them in a position to have to either support
bogus claims of voter fraud or have to denounce
Donald Trump, essentially, and risk.
Being on the receiving end of Trump's anger,
these Republicans are complete fools and they
deserve none of our pity whatsoever.
But the question does become what happens
in the next two years and in the next four
years?
And what I care about is, is there an opportunity
for Joe Biden to get things done?
Because Donald Trump has so debased and destroyed
the Republican Party, the Republican Party
will rebuild and they may even do well in
2022.
I think it's more likely they do well in the
House than the Senate because of the cohort
of Senate elections that are taking place
in 2022.
But the point is, I care about progress and
Joe Biden is going to come in in 13 days and
he'll start doing things that he can do via
executive order.
And that's going to be fine.
And then we don't know if Joe Biden is going
to get any Supreme Court picks, but if he
does, we'll deal with that when it comes to
it.
But the real question is going to be from
the big legislative agenda, from the big policy
agenda, what can Joe Biden get done?
We've said before these Republicans are going
to be the total obstructionists that we've
seen them be in the past.
They are going to get in the way of Joe Biden
doing almost anything with control of the
Senate.
Now 50 50 with Kamala Harris as the tie breaking
vote and continued control of the House with
total government control by Democrats, there
is now a real possibility that some of the
big agenda items can be done.
Can we do a big infrastructure, green energy
deal?
Can we get the public option done and reduce
the Medicare age and make the other changes
that that Joe Biden has lobbied for or campaigned
on?
What is Joe Biden going to be able to do in
terms of foreign policy and foreign relations
and rebuilding?
And the questions around policy are the same
ones.
But with much of the Republican Party now
distancing from Trump, the question is, is
there anything that can be done that will
get a few Republicans to be allies, even if
just for the next two years that give Joe
Biden the opportunity to really get some important
things done?
There are moral questions we could have an
ethical debate about whether, you know, wouldn't
that risk rehabilitating the reputation of
some of these Republicans who don't deserve
that reputation to be OK?
We can have that debate.
But at the end of the day, Trump had this
list of things he was going to do and he failed
to do most of them.
And that's great.
He was going to do his horrible health care
plan.
He failed.
He was going to build a wall and he failed
a lot of the good things he promised.
He also failed on 100 million vaccines by
the end of 2020.
Israeli-Palestinian peace.
You know, the list of things that it would
have been nice to do that he failed on is
also there.
And that's what it is.
The presidency is ending.
What can Joe Biden get done?
And is there any politically strategic way
that these last two weeks during which Trump
denounces his own VP and Republicans start
to distance?
These are still terrible people.
But from the totally pragmatic perspective,
can this be leveraged in any way to get something
done that we really need to get done in this
country?
We'll leave that question there and we'll
pick it up next week.
And certainly when when Joe Biden is ultimately
sworn in,